aquí
[Música]
desde la ciudad de montreal provincia de
québec un saludo a todos nuestros
oyentes e internautas que nos siguen en
este preciso momento en directo por
medio de facebook también de youtube y a
los que nos siguen a través de nuestro
sitio web ynet
punto sea y como siempre les estamos muy
agradecidos a todos por participar en el
programa a través de sus correos
comentarios en nuestro sitio web y en
las redes sociales cómo están ustedes
hoy tenemos aquí en la gran mesa
leonardo gimeno traver da por lobo
martínez eleonora chapman quien les
habla en este preciso momento cómo están
ya las vacaciones
empieza y ya queda poquito aquí las
palomas que tiene hijos chicos cuando es
las escuelas empiezan en septiembre el
lunes antes de septiembre antes de
secundaria empieza en septiembre la
primera semanas después de la misa del
trabajo mi hijo que también mis dos
hijos están en secundaria y depende en
qué zona de la ciudad pero mi hija
comienza el lunes y mi hijo comienza el
viernes y ambos están en el polo maria
me llamó la atención porque en la ribera
sur hay dos escuelas muy grandes la
ribera sur está muy cerquita de montreal
a escasos cinco minutos de autobús media
hora nadando
pero hay dos escuelas muy grandes en la
ribera sur después que pasó yo cada día
cada mañana cuando vengo por aquí y
están en reformas muy grandes a una de
ellas están reformando todo la entrada
estás hablando una reforma física
porque no se están renovando programa
realmente dudo mucho que esté todo listo
para el lunes próximo
un nuevo está en el frente de la escuela
desaparecido de la escuela en realidad
de agregar un gimnasio y cero tiendas
más grande el gran par de aulas a la
escuela donde va mi hijo el más chiquito
empezó a ir y estaba en construcción y
se terminaron de construir antes de que
empezar el invierno en la escuela de mi
hija el año pasado lo que sucedió es que
pusieron nuevos módulos como nuevos
salones de clase pero exteriores no
construidos con con materias concretas
sino por prefabricado escuelas del
futuro tal vez no sabes porque había
muchísimos niños entonces tuvieron que
agregar nuevos salones de clase porque
no había suficiente espacio entonces
toda la toda la parte central al jardín
digamos el patio de la escuela estaba en
construcción durante los primeros meses
todavía bueno entonces las escuelas que
están me imagino que el abuelo también
comenzará ya la actividad parlamentaria
y en la famosa carrera ministerial
porque son las elecciones aquí en canadá
federales en septiembre al igual que en
argentina luís en septiembre ahí vamos a
tener también las elecciones el 21
septiembre es canadá
muy bien las dos en octubre bueno acá
todavía todavía no existe ese fervor que
se vio en la pre elección si se quiere
en argentina una participación dragón 40
llamamos para que hacer bueno entonces
mientras tanto estuve pensando hoy que
habite y no nos vamos a hablar de un
tema y me estaba preguntando uno qué
título podría darle a este tema y me
acordé se me vino a la mente una
película que no sé si ustedes la vieron
arde parís
la famosa película pues me trajo eso a
la memoria y yo dije arde la amazonas el
amazonas está ardiendo es el bosque
tropical más grande del planeta con 7
millones de kilómetros cuadrados canadá
tiene 4 casi 400 millones de bosque
hasta de kilómetros cuadrados en bosques
hay 3 millones más que tiene brasil
cuenta con 400 millones de árboles de
todo tipo y el problema es que el
gobierno de brasil dicen los medios
ignoran las problemáticas ambientales el
instituto nacional de investigaciones
espaciales el link de brasil dijo que
todos estos incendios y los problemas
medioambientales se revé se debe a la
reducción que hizo el presidente
bolsonaro en un 95 por ciento del
presupuesto de acciones destinadas a
preservar ya el medio ambiente a
combatir los incendios etcétera etcétera
antes de hablar un poquito de este tema
vamos a ver un vídeo que tenemos acá que
nos va a dar más o menos una
ambición muy cercana de lo que está
sucediendo en braza
ese es el panorama de la ciudad
recibiendo el distante
para el alumbrado un precio de cinco
días hacia atrás y los paulistas se
preguntaban qué pasaba
más sencilla la explicación para el raro
fenómeno fue la combinación de un frente
frío y el humo emanado a unos tres mil
kilómetros de distancia
la amazonía está ardiendo de forma
alarmante en sólo 16 días el fuego
arrasó 500.000 hectáreas de bosque
tropical y según el centro de
investigación espacial de brasil inpe
sólo en 2019 se han registrado casi 73
mil incendios forestales un 83 por
ciento más que el año pasado en el mismo
periodo aunque el presidente de
bolsonaro tiene su propia y particular
tesis acerca de este inquietante
fenómeno todo con respecto a los
incendios en la amazonía tengo la
impresión de que podrían haber sido
provocados por las ong porque habían
pedido dinero cuál era su intención
traer problemas para brasil la amazonía
es una enorme región selvática que
abarca 9 países y territorios de
sudamérica yo creo que está un poquito
claro de lo que está mostrando este
vídeo creo que sin luz es desesperante y
lo que estuve leyendo entre otras cosas
es que hubo una lluvia negra en sao
paulo firme ustedes la distancia que
marcaban de sao paulo a los focos
y yo vi que llegó hasta argentina al
norte de argentina ya está entré ya
entró a argentina sin hablar de los
países limítrofes con el danzón de
sombra civil el lunes último en san
pablo- oscureció a las 3 de la tarde
es eso y eso estaban hablando de no solo
bueno ya no sólo cómo está el medio
ambiente se está yendo por todos los
huecos donde puede salirse sino está
afectando la salud de la gente y de
manera importante entonces esto es una
catástrofe creo muy importante y lo que
vos estabas comentando esta mañana
louis es que esto tiene repercusiones
incluso ya en europa en europa y
bastante fuertes y de hecho las
repercusiones comenzaron a sellar varios
días cuando noruega entre otras naciones
y alemania que también fueron los dos
los dos primeros países en reaccionar
anular un financiamiento que entregaban
a organizaciones ambientales brasileras
al fondo de premio
y conservación del amazonas más
precisamente debido precisamente las
políticas ambientalistas de evolucionar
agua o la falta de políticas ambientales
del presidente de brasil que ha
recortado como bien lo decías los fondos
a diversas instituciones entre ellas al
instituto de investigaciones espaciales
de brasil que es el que realiza
investigaciones por ejemplo en el
amazonas y el que había advertido uno de
los primeros en advertir de los riesgos
que implicaba la deforestación que está
sufriendo la selva desde que asumió el
actual presidente y abrió esa región del
planeta que está considerada como uno de
los reservorios de biodiversidad más
importantes de la tierra a la
explotación industrial y comercial ese
instituto precisamente por llevar a cabo
estas advertencias sufrió el recorte de
su presupuesto y los ataques continuos
de parte del personal al periodismo
también y si también aquellos conjuntos
y en base a toda esa situación más algo
que no se ha dicho muy frecuentemente
que es el hecho
esta política de explotación comercial
del amazonas trae aparejada la
persecución y actos de violencia de las
tribus indígenas que viven allí de hecho
hay un líder indígena que murió
apuñalado hace unas semanas en
enfrentamientos con gente de una
colaboración de mineras o exactamente de
empresas forestales y
alemania y noruega reaccionaron dijeron
que el presidente de personal no está
haciendo lo suficiente por preservar el
medio ambiente en brasil y retiraron los
fondos quien reacciona hoy y eso sí
tiene mucho peso es el presidente de
francia manuel macrón que dice
textualmente que bolsonaro mintió y
mintió en esa última reunión del g20 que
nos saca en el mes de junio cuando se
comprometió junto con todos los que
asistieron a ese encuentro a preservar
el medio ambiente brasilero y está
demostrado hasta ahora que eso no es así
entonces macro se siente ofendidos por
la mentira que la acusa de la que la
acusa a bolsonaro y amenaza con una
represalia que es muy importante para el
presidente brasil para la región en
general que es impedir que se firme un
acuerdo de libre comercio entre la unión
europea y el mercosur caso por el tema
ambiental ahora al macro ni a los otros
países europeos se acaba también de unir
el primer ministro canadiense trudeau
quien dijo esta mañana ya se encuentra
también en francia o partió a francia
al coro de líderes que están exigiéndole
a bolsonaro que asuma las
responsabilidades y también dijo que
este tema se va a tratar en el g7 que es
lo que algo que bolsonaro se niega
completamente entonces también está la
posición canadiense y yo me preguntaba
hoy leyendo un poco sobre canadá no
canadá el 80% de los recursos forestales
y todo lo que concierne a los bosques
está en manos de los gobiernos
provinciales no hay un 10% que pertenece
totalmente al gobierno federal que son
los grandes parques en fin pero también
tiene el gobierno federal pues su
palabra para decir sobre el resto de
canadá y entre eso se calcula que hay un
6 por ciento de bosques que están en
manos privadas y un 2% un poco más a las
primeras naciones yo me estaba
preguntando hoy porque sabemos lo que
escucho y lo que él dijo sobre brasil
que los terratenientes los agricultores
los grandes propietarios están
provocando incendios les viene muy bien
esto porque lo que ellos quieren es
sembrar
y otras cosas que les terminar con los
bosques teorías y lo interesante sería
saber cuánto de esos bosques del
amazonas están en manos privadas eso tal
vez podría en este momento las tierras
que están enseñando en este momento son
tierras protegidas que forman parecer
amazónica y que no tienen no sé si todas
pero a estas tierras no tienen acceso a
esas empresas por eso están pero quien
practica la tala
por eso están apoyando la postura del
presidente evolucionó de abrir el
espacio de la amazona para la
explotación frontal porque hasta el
momento está protegida esa claro
funcionamiento con respecto a las
acciones que bolsonaro ésta se está
haciendo o no con respecto a eros yo yo
pensé que tenía mayor incidencia la
propiedad privada dentro de los años gel
ya sale otra cosa que nerviosa es que el
centralismo de la política en brasil
hacen que en buena medida estas
políticas dependan del gobierno federal
en brasilia aunque ayer entre otras
cosas que hizo el presidente de
bolsonaro
muy rápido pero echo de culpas al medio
mundo le dijo a los periodistas que le
preguntarán los bordadores que lo que
estaban haciendo no tienen y ahora
volviendo siguiendo un poco acá en
canadá también nosotros acá sufrimos
incendios forestales y como dijimos acá
nada tiene casi 400 millones de
hectáreas de bosques más precisamente en
columbia británica y esta era una nota
que hiciste vos recientemente louis
decías que la temporada de incendios
comenzó comienza el primero de abril y
hasta el momento registró 596 fuegos
incendios de los cuales 29 29 siguen
activos lo cual dice el informe que es
bastante suave este año en comparación a
otros terribles 2017 y 2018 también 17
fue pero 2018 también ahora entonces
todo esto que está sucediendo con estos
bosques hace que la hábitat de los
animales también se vean afectados no
sólo de los seres humanos como otros
factores el deshielo
en fin todo eso entonces los osos por
ejemplo vamos a tomar un ejemplo esta es
una nota que hizo paloma y que también
me parece interesante demostrar la piel
de reportarle paloma se s
el hecho de que cada vez la banquisa se
aleje más de ellos tienen dificultades
en encontrar su comida se están
acercando cada vez más a lugares donde
viven los seres humanos y se producen
tragedias como ésta bueno en este caso
fue la muerte de un joven joven
compositor músico canadiense francés
también que vivió en francia por el
momento
julian gods y que viajó a una región
bastante inhóspita de los territorios
del noroeste de canadá que están en el
norte y en el oeste dejando justamente
ahí se ve el mapa y lo interesante del
caso de este chico es que él había
viajado a otras regiones inhóspitas del
mundo y fue aquí en canadá donde
encontró la muerte con un fuerte con un
ataque que tuvo de un oso grizzly y
ahora en su caso si estaba en una región
aislada pero lo particular de los
ataques que ha habido recientemente
otros osos que hemos reportado aquí en
radio canadá internacional es que son en
zonas cada vez más cercanas a zonas
donde la gente vive en las zonas
residenciales entre otras casas entre
otros casos por ejemplo u otra víctima
que tuvo mucho en la suerte que el joven
francés canadiense porque estaba armado
de un de una navaja el diario fue
grabado el padre antes de todos y
semanas antes
entonces él por suerte pudo sacar el
cuchillo y le dio una cuchillada en el
cuello al oso y se salvó pero él no
estaba muy lejos de donde de su casa
estaba en una región digamos aquí en
contra tenemos varias zonas un poco
boscosas en las afueras de la ciudad
pero no tan lejos digamos en la zona
psicología nos llegaron los ojos los
osos no más al norte al lejano norte a
los territorios cada vez se ve más iba
hablando justamente de estos de estos
osos que se acercan más ya no tienen
miedo incluso se acercan a las vamos a
ver un vídeo que justamente está en este
reportaje paloma donde están unos osos
acercándose bien tarde de la
probabilidad de un
familia en un jardín entonces serán tres
ositos y los podemos se metieron
directamente en la propiedad de la
familia la señora estaba adentro acá me
se metió a su casa estaba regando las
plantas estaba con sus hijos fuera en el
jardín y bueno los osos entraron a su
propiedad y parecen graciosos pero no
son graciosos
porque me hizo acordar a vídeos que he
visto unos cuantos de osos bañándose en
las piscinas
hay una situación muy peligrosa
hay que evitar ese tipo de encuentros
porque los osos programa se sienten
atraídos a atacarlos a los perros para
atacar a todos los perros entonces pues
ese es eso lo que está produciendo todo
este desmadre que está ocurriendo en el
mundo a nivel medioambiental no entonces
y quería agregar solamente un dato vale
me hablaba de montreal no no se mostraba
demostrar lo ocurrido pero cuando llovía
en
en la ciudad de gatineau antes de llegar
aquí a montreal hace unos cuantos años
gatti no está enfrente de ottawa
nacional que sí que está en la franja
sur de canadá donde se concentra la
mayor población del país y yo tenía
conocidos en gatineau que vivían en
casas con parques muy muy grandes en
todo caso a mí me parecían muy grandes
en ese momento y ellos recibían
continuamente la visita de osos en sus
jardines es decir no están aquí en
montreal pero sí han llegado a la franja
sur no están solamente en el norte yo he
visto un vídeo en el lejano norte no me
acuerdo si era nunavut o en los
territorios del noroeste o el yukón uno
de esos ya sea este tiempo donde se ve
se veía un oso en la banquisa que
resbalaba porque quería
para ir a buscar comida en realidad es
eso sí y además este año por ejemplo que
yo estuve en el norte de quebec lo que
me dijo mi suegra que conoce bien esa
zona es no es
frutillas porque en las cantaban cambio
exactamente si tú ves él está muy seco
no había llovido poco y había pocas
frutas de las pequeñas no moritas o
frambuesas incluso de las que se
alimentan porque nacen así junto a los
grandes resorts silvestres de silvestre
de forma silvestre y no había este año
generalmente nos vamos a juntar un poco
para hacer una tarta
los osos se acercan los especialistas
también cuando uno se enfrenta con el
momento no hay que hacer ruido
hay que cortar hay que intentar hacer
ruido cuando uno los ve para evitar que
se acerquen y una vez que el animal que
está cerca permanecer lo más tranquilo
que se pueda básicamente a veces el
terror de paisajes te puede ayudar pero
no correr en todo caso no poner por qué
porque soy salvo que es lo que hizo lo
que hizo mal fue que con uno de esos
palos que sirven para caminar en
senderismo le pegó en la cara
en lugar de quedarse quieto y sin
moverse lo trató de asustar pegándole y
era lo peor que podía haber hecho porque
dicen ojuelos ahora a la aplicación
leonardo es tu turno
para explicar para explicar por qué
tendríamos que tener esta aplicación de
radio canadá internacional que es mucho
más rápido porque es mucho más fácil
porque es de una clara y aparte de una
posibilidad de toda la información está
condensada en nuestra aplicación así que
para que los que tengan la posibilidad
porque está demostrado que casi el 50 y
algo por ciento 52.3 por ciento de la
gente que entra a nuestro sitio internet
lo hace desde un teléfono entonces
aprovechando eso esos datos sería
interesante que la gente pudiera probar
la aplicación para que vea
lo interesante que es tener todo nuestro
contenido en esa boca de entrar en ese
mismo lugar está bien y que tiene
posibilidades enormes en cuanto a si
usted por ejemplo yo tengo problemas de
vista puedo agrandar las letras para
guardar cosas para leer después offline
o sea realmente la posibilidad es muy
amplia si uno hace el esfuerzo y baja la
aplicación entonces las lenguas hay
invitados todos en el costado a la
derecha arriba de nuestro sitio de
internet de la pequeña publicidad ahí
hacen clic y están las dos opciones para
los que tengan android para que tengan
iphone y pueden bajar directamente la
aplicación en sus teléfonos muy bien
entonces está clarito
ahora vamos a pasar al segmento de
nuestros oyentes que no se moje antes
hablando de los oyentes en los que nos
están viendo si ellos por ejemplo estoy
pensando en los países limítrofes con
brasil si hay alguien ahí que nos está
escuchando y nos puede decir cuál es que
es lo que están diciendo en esos lugares
sobre estos incendios de la amazona
tenemos
partes en bolivia bolivia perú colombia
y colombia ya tiene experiencia en
prevención de incendios de bosques y le
ofreció a bolsonaro junto con los países
la región ir a actuar inmediato el
presidente macri también oficioso
aquí tenemos entonces saludos de rob orf
que dice hola después nancy
irreversibilidad que está en brasil
desde brasil le preguntamos si tiene
alguna información que no llegue que nos
salga al exterior que nosotros vamos a
ver
gustavo lucas saludos desde la ciudad de
melo en uruguay el balear pero
probablemente si hay una nube grande
pero probablemente se llevó a la
argentina ha pasado por uruguay
dependencia con el norte y todavía no
bajó pero es probable dependiendo de los
de los vientos están si y saludos desde
mundo argentina daniel camporini
danielle camporini también él siempre
nos escribe a ver si hay alguna novedad
sobre lo que está pasando en brasil con
el amazonas y ahora sí vamos con
nuestros oyentes que nos envían
comentarios sobre nuestros reportajes
entonces vamos a comenzar a leonardo que
tienes aquí tengo un médico canadiense
dice que la diabetes tipo 2 es curable y
emilio nos mandó un mensaje dice gracias
por compartir con nosotros esta valiosa
información
emilio está respondiendo a mari que
también había escrito sobre este tema es
efectivamente como explica este artículo
el control de la diabetes es algo muy
importante para todos aquellos que la
padecemos se deben considerar aspectos
tan sensibles como nuestra nutrición el
control de peso y buena actividad física
que son la clave para mantenerse bien
particularmente he estado mirando una
serie de recomendaciones que han ayudado
a mantener controlada mi diabetes hasta
el punto que ya no usa insulina así que
es muy buena
emilio que padece de esta enfermedad que
en realidad es un flagelo mundial y si
está aumentando
escuché que de hace dos décadas a esta
altura
quebequense promedio ha aumentado cuatro
talles en 20 años
lo que ha aumentado la obesidad la
obesidad abdominal que es además un
elemento que los médicos están teniendo
más en cuenta que la masa de índice
corporal porque la masa del problema
incluye en el peso a la grasa muscular
que no tiene que ver con obesidad en
cambio la talla del abdomen es un índice
más claro más certero de obesidad y de
problemas que pueden traer aparejada la
obesidad y la grasa abdominal masculina
es
tienen tiene un condimento muy especial
que nos inicial ni ajo que
es lo que provoca no sólo la grasa que
conforman ese tipo de grasa es lo que
provoca altísimo riesgo de tener
problemas cardíacos en la grasa
probablemente no estoy seguro no quiero
decir especial tiene que ver con la
grasa masculina
si yo tengo un mensaje que nos envía a
javier gonzález nungaray sobre el tema
geóloga canadiense descubrió el agua más
vieja de la tierra en ontario y ella
javier dice una investigación muy
interesante pero también de mucho
trabajo y aplicación de la geóloga
canadiense barber sherwood buscar y
encontrar el agua más vieja de la tierra
cordiales 73 a todos en rs y que es el
mensaje javier gonzález nungaray de
mexico
paloma si tengo aquí un mensaje de juan
carlos no nos dice su apellido
sobre la nota granjero canadiense regala
su tierra a una condición me llamo juan
de colombia excelente la oferta en
realidad estoy de acuerdo que quien
quiera hacerse a cargo de la granja sea
en persona que le guste trabajo una
persona que le gusta trabajar cuidando
los animalitos y que haya sido del campo
y que por ende le encante en las labores
del campo o de las granjas personalmente
me gustaría distracción pero sea eso
creo que se lo dieron a dos mujeres
una pareja de mujeres extranjeras y
extranjeras que se ofrecieron el que no
me acuerdo si era era en el oeste
canadiense yo me acuerdo derecho ese
tema y no sé no me proviene el lugar
pero el dueño de esa granja tenía un
trato muy particular tenía muchísimos
animales de esos que a los animales los
acaricia y que cuando van a comer los
están contentos por mí se dan cuenta que
los matan entonces es una de las
exigencias era justamente que tuvieran
darles maltrato con los animales y por
supuesto tenga amor en el vídeo y
todavía porque él ya no estaba en
condiciones de seguir entonces se
presentó mucha gente bueno aguantarlo la
próxima vez que hay una oferta maja y
ponte al ponte al tanto
bueno aquí yo tengo dos o tres cerditos
en tu mensaje
luís alfredo marín dice saludos desde
santias ente en quebec canadá
llamada lalín dice saludos desde
venezuela muy bien el fuego también debe
estar llegando por ahí así que salió
para todos los gracias por estar en
sintonía con nosotros yo tengo aquí
comentarios dos comentarios de un tema
que hizo luis verónica anderson angers
una que me cansa enamorada del perú que
tuvo muchísimas versiones sobre la
muchísima prensa dice jefferson vargas
bellido dice como peruano opinó que la
señorita verón y que es una gran mujer
muchas personas deberían de seguir su
ejemplo valorar y aprovechar las
oportunidades que existen en mi país la
discriminación falta de disciplina y
valores que existen en el perú son una
barrera invisible que impide el
desarrollo lamentablemente es un proceso
de mejora muy lento bueno es lento pero
hay mejora es lo que dice jefferson y
después tiene johnny que no sea aquí no
nos dice su éxito
me encantó la entrevista a una dama a la
que sigo por facebook
vivo en eeuu así que es imposible no
sentir simpatía por ella puesto que en
algún momento también cada uno de los
que viven lejos de su país sienten lo
mismo
leonardo sí aquí tengo otro mensaje en
este caso es roberto hernández y estoy
haciendo una prueba leer con lentes así
las cosas no sé buenas tardes metamos
roberto hernández tengo sentís en él
siento un trasplante tengo familia que
está dispuesta a donar parte de su
hígado en su fundación hay de apoyo para
la operación soy de méxico dice y qué
costo tendría que pagar ya para poder
ser seleccionado o transportado para
bueno para poder hacer el trasplante
gracias son muchos datos que nosotros
lamentablemente no podemos corroborar
exactamente así que lo interesante sería
que se pudiera poner en contacto con la
clínica que ofrece este tipo de
de tratamientos para indagar cuáles son
los requisitos que está la información
esta letra mención siempre louis bueno
yo tengo otro mensaje de javier gonzález
nungaray pero en este caso sobre el tema
del cambio climático es la mayor amenaza
para la salud dicen médicos canadienses
y dice saludos a todos en recibir
nuevamente hablamos del cambio climático
como quizás se hace muy repetitivo pero
la verdad es que en todos los niveles y
en todo el mundo urge un cambio de
mentalidad del ser humano y un actuar
bien definido con respecto a una
relación sustentable con la naturaleza
aumentar el volumen de áreas verdes
cuidar el uso de los combustibles de
manera consciente migrar a las energías
solares y también producidas por el
viento ese mensaje se habla mucho de
cambio climático y se va a hablar cada
vez más evidentemente hasta lo más tengo
un mensaje de claudia negrón sobre el
tema la feliz y afortunada historia de
inmigración de un cardiólogo es un
reportaje que hizo pablo recuerdo min y
claudia negrón dice que lindo el
reportaje mi nombre es claudia y trabajo
en el hospital en donde pablo el doctor
el cardiólogo
hizo su residencia el mundo es chico un
abrazo desde mar del plata los quiero y
los recuerdo claudia negro muchas
gracias claudia tengo acá un mensaje
sobre el tema comida rápida saludable la
ensalada de mcdonald tiene más calorías
que una hamburguesa doble sí señor
la ensalada es el condimento la salsita
y le ponemos en los dientes que estamos
millones de arrojados sano porque está
comiendo lechuga con salsa ahora dice
julio comenta estoy dice increíble pese
a las diferentes campañas que se han
realizado en contra de esta campaña para
que realicen tengan alimentos más
saludables todavía siguen sacando
productos como éste en mi parecer dice
en mi par en mi parecer países de la
unión europea como italia deben generar
más conciencia en sus ciudadanos para el
consumo de estos alimentos hay que
evitar el fast food o comer comida
congelada siempre la comida casera será
mejor claro que con la comida casera
alguien tiene que cocinar
dice pero bueno dice pero vamos el
comprarte en medio kilo de carne picada
a línea y aliñar la al gusto poner un
buen queso verdura fresca recién cortada
lo que decía leonardo y con tus propias
salsas siempre estará más bueno y mejor
preparado que una hamburguesa de comida
rápida muy bien yo creo que julio dice
[Música]
pero hacer una hamburguesa casera
albóndiga en argentina casi un poquito
más chata y eso le pones tomate y
lechuga como buddies y ya está
estamos con un poquito de aceite de
oliva pero nada de ponerle esa sal citas
especiales
también hay ahora usted se meten a
cualquier red social y hay lugares donde
ofrecen 30 40 50 tipos diferentes de
aderezos preparados con alimentos
naturales de que se podría hacer de otra
manera lo pasa es que en la
industrialización para que todo el mundo
tenga el mismo tipo de salsa desde no sé
el mcdonald más lejano en áfrica hasta
el mcdonald de ruiz ya central park o
rusia necesariamente tienen que
industrializar lo y ponerle estos
químicos y cosas que no son tan buenas
para la salud a ustedes ya les ha pasado
de comprar queso que vence ocho meses
más tarde
diez meses y dices yo he hablado viendo
yo hablamos llegado con una persona que
trabaja en una empresa alimenticia
enorme en eeuu
comentó que todas las fechas de
vencimiento son aproximadas aproximadas
primero se orientan más relacionadas con
la comercialización que exacto consuela
el consumo si uno mantiene en
especialmente por ejemplo en los quesos
yogures ese tipo de cosas si uno
mantiene la cadena de frío se puede
comer dos meses más tarde
8 a 10 meses es lo que estoy hablando de
estos quesos no sueles mal y eso debe
ser parecido
justamente no te hablo de los quesos
cheddar estos comunes y corrientes el
otro día fui a comprar uno en febrero
marzo del 2010 no me enteré de 2020 no
lo compre para conocer lo que tiene cero
activos le están poniendo a esos
alimentos para que tengan esa duración y
nombrar cosas hechas eso en las
localidades porque es lo que está más
fresco en lo local y no volverse un
amigo mío trabaja en una empresa activa
muy importante aquí entonces no lo vamos
a nombrar
pero él se lleva a yogur que la misma
empresa no alcanza a comercializar y
como tiene una fecha de vencimiento ya
no puede enviar a los comercios y me
regala mi formación
pero dices que tu amigo hable español
porque lo podías invitar a que nos
demuestre aquí que pongan lo bueno ahora
sí tenemos que ir a los temas de la
semana cada uno destaca como ya es
costumbre en este programa un tema y por
qué tienen que explicar por qué lo
consideran importante y como siempre
vamos a empezar
leonardo porque a mí me encanta
demasiado porque yo esos temas que vos
desarrolla a mí me presentan importantes
y además lo confieso cada vez pierde más
confianza sino dos tipos entonces en
estos tipos de tecnología entonces lo
que vos estás trayendo hoy es que hay se
ha formado un consorcio para protegernos
exacto y es para una instancia del
internet que uno no tiene muy en cuenta
sin embargo uno pasa mucho tiempo allí
adentro y es el lugar menos protegido
está bien el tema es éste en este
contexto de lo que está pasando hoy en
día que encontramos que una carta de
crédito le robaron 12 millones de
credenciales de un sitio internet de
citas perdió la base de datos de 15
millones de personas bueno en ese
contexto de robo constante de
información microsoft google intel
alibaba baidu e ibm y bret hart y
tencent entre otras
armaron un consorcio para ver si pueden
lograr hacer de la privacidad algo más
seguro y sobre todo en una instancia
particular como decía el principio que
es
la persona está en contacto porque
cuando los datos están parados en el
servidor están protegidos cuando el dato
está en el teléfono está protegido el
dato no está protegido cuando lo estamos
usando enviándoles devolviendo así que
en este caso cuando dejamos de ser los
dueños exacto y en este caso lo que
están haciendo estas empresas que tienen
digamos una coincidencia en realidad no
es coincidencia lo han hecho justamente
propósito empresas líderes en hardware
software proveedores de servicios del
nuevo de desarrolladores expertos en
código abierto y académicos que se
juntaron para lograr algo que sea más
fiable en cuanto a la seguridad que en
ese proceso particular que es en el
envío en la transferencia de datos que
es cuando más se pierde de acuerdo pues
ahí estaremos uno más
vamos a ver queda louis a ver tienes un
tema sobre niños chilenos con problemas
cognitivos que vinieron a canadá a
presentar un espectáculo y entonces por
qué te pareció importante destacar
bueno este fin de semana va a haber un
espectáculo en la ribera sur perdón en
la ribera norte de montreal en la
localidad de la vall realizado por estos
chicos que vienen con la fundación de
ley que es una fundación de chile de uno
de los suburbios
necesitados de santiago de chile son
chicos con capacidad con discapacidad
intelectual en todo caso con problemas
de aprendizaje de comportamiento y este
este grupo tiene una escuela allí que le
brinda educación y contención asistencia
social a 200 y pico de los niños y
jóvenes niños y adolescentes un grupo de
ellos había sido invitado por una
organización aquí a montreal para que
presentara un espectáculo cuando todo el
procedimiento de preparación estaba ya
en marcha la inversión hecha y el
esfuerzo casi completo que ese organismo
decidió retirar la invitación y entonces
hispanidad quebec que aglutina a la
comunidad hispánica en general o latina
en general se propuso permitir y se
contrataron por la con la fundación creo
que los contacto entonces ellos
comenzaron a movilizar a la gente para
que reuniera los fondos y conseguir a
los lugares en donde este espectáculo
pudiese llevarse a cabo
además alojar a la gente porque vieron
en total por aquí tengo el número exacto
20 niños y 14 adultos decir es un grupo
bastante importante
numerosos son chicos que tienen como
objetivo principal asegurar su
integración social a partir de
expresiones artísticas como las que van
a poner en práctica este fin de semana
que espectáculo como yo decía se lleva a
cabo el día 25 el domingo en la
localidad de la vall hay un reportaje
puesto en nuestro sitio internet desde
el viernes pasado donde están todos los
datos para aquellos que quieran asistir
y hay una entrevista a cuatro personas
al responsable de hispanidad que ve a la
directora del colegio de la fundación
shelley y a dos de los chicos de los
veintipico que vinieron en total que
creo que es interesante escuchar
interesante y emocionante dijiste porque
sí bueno de hecho se emocionaron ellos
bueno los chicos cuando le pregunté
porque para él era importante esta
fundación él dijo bueno porque y se le
quebró la voz al decirlo
la mayoría de nosotros pensamos en algún
momento ser padres y nunca sabemos si el
hijo podrá venir con problemas él lo
dijo con la voz quebrada qué cosa
profunda pero dos las invitadas se
pusieron a llorar en medio de la
entrevista con movidas por lo que este
chico había dicho emocionada por lo que
este chico había dicho así que hubo
también es cierto emoción ahí y creo que
vale la pena escuchar la entrevista pero
más que nada
respecto al espectáculo en un
espectáculo voy a darle una sólo uno
solo y solamente en montreal solamente
en lavada
y el resto del tiempo libre que no es
mucho lo van a utilizar para recorrer un
poco montreal para conocer otra agua
para ir a ver el jardín botánico y para
visitar el estadio olímpico de la ciudad
muy bien gracias luis ahora vamos a otro
tema un tema muy diferente en este caso
paloma conducta empresarial responsable
activistas acusan al primer ministro
todo de traición suena bastante fuerte
suena fuerte porque resulta que
recientemente el mes pasado el mes de
julio 14 representantes de un grupo que
se había creado que había sido creado
por el gobierno de crudo que se llama el
grupo consultativo multipartita sobre
conducta empresarial responsable en el
extranjero entonces 14 representantes de
la sociedad civil y de sindicatos
canadienses renunciaron en bloque a este
gran productor en protesta porque dicen
que el gobierno canadiense traicionó la
confianza de las organizaciones de la
sociedad civil en lo referente al
compromiso de canadá con la
responsabilidad corporativa en el
extranjero particularmente con
a compañías mineras en el extranjero
mineras canadienses la razón por la que
dicen que los traicionó es que el
compromiso del gobierno canadiense desde
la campaña electoral de las promesas que
hizo fue crear una oficina violaron un
defensor o defender una defensoría del
pueblo defensoría de los ciudadanos
ombudsman que tuviera las habilidades de
investigar las quejas que había contra
compañías canadienses accionando en el
extranjero e ir a ver que estaba pasando
y por qué la gente se estaba quejando de
la presencia canadiense fuera de canadá
entonces el gobierno crudo creó la
compra
la oficina del ombudsman pero lo que no
le dio como
como opción a esta oficina es la
posibilidad de investigar no le dio el
mandato que necesitaba y es decir no le
dio el mandato que hice que haría que la
gente exija transparencia extra y la
información porque para eso lo han
creado rendición de cuentas
exageraciones o lo que se dice que es
una democracia hay que rendir cuenta
entonces ahora está esta oficina no
puede exigir con documentos de las
compañías ni citar testigos entonces no
puede investigar las quejas en contra de
las compañías es por eso estos
activistas lo lo tacharon de traicionero
al no cumplir con lo prometido
si yo tengo un reportaje también en su
reportaje en estos momentos en suiza se
está llevando a cabo una reunión
importantísima de sites es su sigla en
inglés convención sobre el comercio
internacional de especies amenazadas de
fauna y flora silvestres y conversé con
joaquín de la torre que es director de
ifaw él pronunció así en inglés en
español para américa latina y el caribe
que es una ong de bienestar animal con
estatus especial
en las naciones unidas en esta reunión
lo que él expresa es que se va a
discutir y no es la primera vez ya hubo
otras en otras reuniones anteriores
comercio de elefantes del marfil que
siguen pues el marfil salsa vemos ya que
da beneficios importantes a los
cazadores y a los que les pagan a los
cazadores también se habla por primera
vez de protección de jirafas esta es la
primera vez ellos calculan que las
jirafas se han reducido en un 40% en los
últimos 30 años también porque por el
comercio internacional que se hace de
estas especias ilegal a la pérdida de sí
claro los tiburones también están
disminuyendo sobre todo debido a la
demanda de sus aletas y de carne lo que
le pregunta específicamente aquí vemos a
joaquín en la fotografía es que animales
necesitaban que me dé una idea de
américa latina también eso y me habló de
algo que tuvo mucho éxito es un proyecto
en argentina y en chile se logró
proteger a la vicuña que estaba en serio
peligro
no decían todavía de extinción pero de
reducción lograron revertir ese concepto
hoy pues están paseando alegremente las
vicuñas y también el dijo que hay otros
proyectos de méxico el salvador para en
ponerla a la iguana también en la lista
de animales con posibilidades de ganar
saneamiento pues desde no sé si
desaparecer pero con serio peligro de
achicarse su número las ramitas de
cristal también hablan que están en
serio peligro y me queda dos bueno y le
pregunté cuáles especies se podría
extinguir en américa latina y hablo de
la vaquita marina que lamentablemente ya
nos quedan 20 especies nada más y esa
experiencia que nos tienes 20 individuos
y el méxico que seguir viendo también
existiendo si el tiempo aquí tengo un
saludo de javier gonzález nunca sabe qué
dice quiero disculparme por haber estado
presente en los programas anteriores
cuando hay algo muy grande y luis
balderas desde san antonio chile también
está presente miran muchísimas gracias
será entonces hasta la próxima hasta el
próximo viernes
y gracias por habernos acompañado
aquí
[Música]
e